weakness in the D I want to keep
counting on it and let least until some
kind of adjustment is made by the
opponent
we've got a great game on our hands as
we welcome you back the fourth quarter
of action getting started warriors trail
by three the incredible shooting pair of
curry and Thompson to the backcourt
Iguodala out there with Durant and it's
green in at the center that's the
Warriors five fans are really getting
their money's worth tonight what an
entertaining ballgame this is what they
pay the seat I quality basketball
between two outstanding teams at the top
of their game the Bulls making a switch
here Gibson's checked in
Paul's knocked loose here is Durant
here's the three drills the three
pointer and the Warriors lead by three
you have to respect everything the dirac
can do on the floor you have to live
with it I mean when he knocks down that
pull-up jumper crazy here's Rondo the
shots good on the assist by Butler yeah
three consecutive field goals have come
right at the rim the D had better start
buckling down
here's curry it's going to be two
free-throws drew contact on the shot
and everyone remembers the Warriors
regular season last year but Chris the
highlight of all of it had to be the
beginning they rattled off a record 24
consecutive wins to start the season
whoa kevin what is most amazing to me
about how to started their season with
was how they were able to keep their
focus when you are on a win streak like
that everyone is gunning for you you
have the bullseye on your back they're
giving you the best game that they've
got their focus also helped the Warriors
with their lengthy homestreet you have
to be as tough as nails mentally to
reach win streaks like that but Julia
please check in for Andre Iguodala and
what an advantage you really feel like
you can always trust him when he's at
the line
rondell against curry
Gibson with a screen on Durant and it's
Butler missing if that would have been
lucky had it fallen or shot selection
well that's just how wise to take that
shot in that situation you'll think
better of it next time Curry's shot is
good he is almost as hard to stop her
son as he is out i mean curry just
finishes that wiry frame and speed of
his he can still get to the hoop and
finish strong now here's Rondo but Julia
with the steal
curry with it he's picked up by Rondo
they double-team curry shut up all
so in Chicago now here's Golden State
now they've gone on a 10-2 run not
allowing much we knew that clay is one
of the most explosive scorers in the
game that much was clear Chris when he
put up his record-setting 37 points in
the quarter and attention to all
defenders with clay it doesn't matter
what you do if he is in that zone he is
tall enough not to be bothered by the
hands in his face and can just drill a
shot from anywhere that's why he's a
danger to put up 20 or more points in
the quarter every time he takes the
floor just like his other splash brother
he doesn't get the second one now there
was a time early in his career where
klay Thompson had to live outside the
arc to get his point he will float to
space in the mid-range pull up off of a
drive or stay behind the arc he has
expanded his game from instant in the
last few seasons and it's a dynamic
support
Durant no good not quite enough defense
that time around just lucky he was off
and counted the shot is good he'll go to
the free-throw line moving it around
eight of their last 10 coming off
assists and with clay the number one way
that he's diversified his offense
Chris's that he does a better job of
getting to the rim and Italian offenders
off the by the Lang ya as a younger
player he had the quickness to beat the
defender but he had trouble finishing
now something clicked for him during
that time and now he welcomes the
contact getting that easy bucket at the
free-throw line knowing when he finishes
he converts contested layups as well as
anyone he identified a weakness in his
game and rectified it Golden State's
gone two or three in the fourth quarter
from long range good shooting so far
it's very outside rebound by the Bulls
Wade's got his third rebound on the
night I wonder what the score would be
if they weren't controlling the
backboard mirror ditch gets the bucket
time running low guys and somebody has
got to win this one yeah well who knows
we might need overtime and this one it's
been that kind of a game and that one is
good are you got to try to cook hurry
off that's how he makes you pay for a
quick pull-up
rondo against curry Butler kicks Tamara
touch the kick outside to Butler off
target with his three the Warriors have
gotten for the six shots to thaw so far
here in the fourth of pretty nice
efficiency there Durant for three
unable to get that one and the Bulls
going the other way now
out to the right way meritage has a wide
open look it's good coming on the assist
by Rajon Rondo how many times have we
seen a possession take that from them
today ending with a basket coming off a
pretty packed trains the three-pointer
Curry's got 12 points now in the corner
and now looks like we've got an injury
here guys will likely see him come out
of the game oh man you just hate to see
something like that Oh users trust me an
unfortunate part of the game you know
he's got to be frustrated Shaun
Livingston he's checked in for Steph
Curry Lopez he's checked in for Chicago
and that's out of bounds Accardo will
retain possession well closed to fishing
that one off oh he gets a great jump
when it barely bounces off his
fingertips
well if you're just tuning in welcome
we've got about three and a half minutes
gone here on the fourth quarter
outside Rondo Butler sets a screen for
onda an easy layup ever coming off the
pit and the Bulls leave by 12 both teams
trading punches back and forth this
thing's like a heavyweight fight I think
a good indication of that this will be
an absolute battle for the entirety of
this game now here is meritage feeds at
dorando and it's lopen that time on the
assist by Rondo hey guys all about hard
work from this point on that they'd
worked hard to create get high quality
shot and then able to knock the dead
Livingston with it he's covered by Rondo
and the
that's foul number two for him Taj
Gibson's checked in for Mirotic
Durant the pastor Thompson
jacks up a three throws it from outside
Johnson's got for this quarter and Kevin
when you really need a bucket go to one
of the premier scores in this game play
Thompson
nasta Butler
it's rebounded by Durant
Golden State's gone for seven with the
long ball here in the fourth quarter
and again it's true Thompson with the
triple
now it's a three point
final quarter these guys are had
just burying the threes in bunches I
mean and they can knock them down but
this is all because of good ball
movement they are getting wide open
shots do the how they are zipping the
ball around the court the deep I just
can't keep up and here are the Bulls now
the Warriors making the shot outside
Butler
here's the teardrop it's good coming on
the assist by Rajon Rondo 11 points for
Butler takes what the defense allows as
that soft floater in his back for three
Durant and another three for Golden
State and they clearly are just
destroying this group right now from the
three-point line they're taking any look
they can get from there just making it
rain from the perimeter right now money
and now they trail by just for heat
buckets and we know he delivers down the
stretch he shines when it matters most
they love getting him the rock and key
situations like that
here's Cutler
is it alive it's hold in by Kevin Durant
basket here in this game maybe all yeah
but but the main priority kevin has to
be taking care of the basketball and
using the five livingston that's good
Chicago calls time mark they trail by
six there's 25 seconds left in the
fourth quarter of this one
love the energy fellas I really do now
we got to keep it up and stay focused do
not give them any life out there
understood
dishes at the butler 13 feet away it's
good and now they trail by just four so
versatile always pushing the action
offensive
19 seconds left in the fourth quarter
and they go to the intentional foul had
to foul and on that occasion to stop the
clock that's the enemy in this situation
right on the first and that puts them up
by five
so it gets them both and it's a
six-point ball anything you know
mistakes they're good free throws we
give them over here guys hustle up let's
talk
hey he let up on deep even a little it's
enough to get there guy girl how many
times do I have to repeat myself
a pointer Butler missing again and
that's an intentional foul
t
so the first one drops and that makes it
a seven-point lead
and he cannot convert on the second pet
mrs. Valentine dishes de Lopez grant
gets a wide open look off target from
three-point range so we see the Warriors
get the win here probably a little
closer than they would have liked it but
a win nonetheless yeah but I really got
a sense that the fans gave them that
emotional boost that was needed down the
stretch this crowd man they were
electric just not